Hello everyone, and welcome to this session on Twinmotion to Unreal Engine.
My name is Amer Yassine and I will be your guide today.
The purpose of this class is to show you how to export your Twinmotion project to
Unreal Engine for further processing.
We'll cover the recommended workflows, as well as tips and tricks to ensure the best
compatibility between the two apps.
You'll first learn about setting the stage, and what plugins you need to help with the
transfer.
You'll then learn to ingest the Twinmotion data into Unreal Engine in a couple of different
ways, before you learn to manage lights, levels of detail and collisions.
Finally, you will learn how to fix or replace those effects that didn't transfer properly.
We'll be using Twinmotion Community Edition 2023.2 and Unreal Engine 5.3 for this class.
And so, if you're ready, let's start!